Iyaloo Akuunda ist etwas nervös.
Gerade mal fünf Monate lernt sie Deutsch,
jetzt muss sie schon ihr erstes
Vorstellungsgespräch
in dieser Sprache führen.
Mitarbeiter vom deutschen
Uniklinikum Düsseldorf
sind darum extra nach Namibia gekommen.
Ich heiße Iyaloo Akuunda.
Ich bin 23 Jahre alt.
Ich bin nicht verheiratet,
ich habe keine Kinder,
und nach meinem Abschluss gibt [gab] es
nicht viele Arbeitsmöglichkeit[en],
deshalb habe ich keine …
nicht viel Erfahrung.
Akuunda hat an der Uni
Krankenpflege studiert,
doch im Anschluss keinen Job gefunden.
So ging es vielen ihrer Kommilitonen.
Denn Namibias Wirtschaft
steckt in einer Krise.
Der Gesundheitsminister will zwar 4000
weitere Pflegekräfte einstellen,
doch für mehr fehle das Geld.
Namibia ist eines der wenigen Länder Afrikas,
das mehr Krankenpfleger ausbildet,
als es einstellen kann.
Dass die arbeitslosen Fachkräfte
eine Weile ins Ausland gehen,
ist für ihn eine gute Lösung.
Deutschland ist ein entwickeltes Land.
Sie benutzen High-Tech
und haben andere Lösungsansätze
und andere Bedingungen.
Es ist gut, etwas Neues kennenzulernen.
Sie lernen etwas, dann kommen
sie zurück und wenden es an.
Es wird viel über Brain-Drain in
afrikanischen Ländern gesprochen.
Aber Namibia ist davon nicht betroffen.
Die Personalbeschaffungsfirma
von Tilman Frank
hat die 16 Krankenpfleger ausgewählt
und zahlt den Deutschkurs,
der sie für den deutschen
Markt fit machen soll.
Mehr als 1000 Pfleger aus 12 Ländern hat
Frank bereits nach Deutschland geholt.
Wenn eine Klinik die Pfleger nimmt,
bekommt seine Firma eine Prämie.
Deutschlands Bevölkerung wird älter
und immer weniger junge Menschen
wollen in der Pflege arbeiten.
Also, die Nachfrage ist gigantisch.
Also, die deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft
hat von 60.000 fehlenden
Pflegekräften gesprochen.
Mit der Sprache und der Berufsanerkennung
– dann werden die einem
aus der Hand gerissen.
Die Vorstellungsgespräche in
Windhoek sind unterdessen vorbei.
Das Team vom Uniklinikum ist begeistert.
Wir haben über Sie gesprochen,
über jeden Einzelnen.
Wir hatten Sie ja alle im Interview.
Und ich kann Ihnen sagen, dass wir vom
Klinikum entschieden haben,
dass wir Sie alle gerne in Düsseldorf hätten.
Der Job ist in der Tasche,
jetzt müssen die Krankenpfleger
nur noch die Sprachprüfung bestehen.
Dann geht es bereits im April
nach Düsseldorf.